- We are back and no, you do
not have to adjust your TV.
Kelly did not become
an Asian man overnight.
I'm Simu Liu filling
in for Kelly Clarkson.
And you know, one of the things
that I love about this
show is Kelly's passion
for shining a light on
people, doing great things.
And since it's my show for the day,
I'm excited for you to meet my next guest.
He's the fan founder of
the digital content creator
Jubilee Media.
Their mission is to bring people together
through empathy and connection.
Now you may have heard of one
of his most popular series
called Spectrum, and he's
also one of my best friends.
Please welcome Jason Y. Lee.
(audience cheering)
(Jason laughing)
I know your story but for people who don't
how did you found your company?
How did you found Jubilee?
- Yeah.
As you know, I'm a child
of Korean immigrants.
So I had a very traditional
view on what my life
and what my career and what
success would look like.
So after I graduated
from Penn, I went to Bein
and in 2010 my 22nd birthday
happened to coincide
with a Haiti earthquake.
Which was kind of a crazy turn of events
and I just felt like this
incredible need to do something.
So I decided to go to
a New York subway stop
to sing in a bus to raise
$100 dollars for Haiti
which you know is a crazy
idea because unlike you
and Kelly, I'm a terrible singer.
But that day-
- You're an A for effort singer.
- Yes
I try my best.
That day we made 80 bucks,
I made my very first video,
put it online.
Within a week we had tens
of thousands of views
and I think that's when,
I kind of the light
bulb went off in my head
of this is what I wanna do.
I wanna create content.
I wanna create a movement
where people believe in empathy
and kindness and connection,
and that started Jubilee.
So since then we have over 6 million,
7 million subscribers now.
We have had 2 billion views.
We made our very first
feature documentary.
So, I'm just so proud to
be starting a movement
that provokes understanding
and human connection.
- That's incredible.
I, I've always loved your story
and your propensity for, for empathy.
I think that's why when they
asked me to host the show
your name kind of
immediately came to mind.
You're one of my favorite
people in the world.
I'm so glad that America
now gets to meet you.
So, so explain Spectrum.
Explain what the Spectrum
series is all about.
- So spectrum was one of
our very first viral shows
and it really is a show
where we would bring people
that seem like they're in the same group,
like a very homogenous
group like do all men
or do all teen moms think the same.
And obviously the answer is no.
But we put them in a warehouse
and we'll have them line
up from strongly disagree
all the way to strongly agree.
And we'll ask questions
that are intended to
provoke real conversation.
I think one thing that we're
really missing right now
is just true dialogue.
It doesn't mean we have
to agree on everything
but how can we actually
listen to each other,
examine our beliefs and
see how we are similar
and sometimes different?
So we're really proud of it.
We had over 300 million views to the show
and what happened was a
lot of clubs and students
and teachers actually
started using this format
in their classrooms.
And we said, you know what?
We have to do something about it.
So we actually decided to
make our very first game.
So we actually made a card set
based on Spectrum.
- [Simu Liu] Amazing.
- Yeah.
- Amazing.
And, and we're, we don't
have the cards with us,
but, but you did bring
the game Spectrum here.
- Yes.
We have, you know, our
own way of playing it
on the Kelly Clarkson show.
- We're gonna play the abridged version.
- That's right.
And, and Ruben, the show's
fearless, warm up guy
has actually agreed to play with us.
So-
- [Jason] Look at his outfit.
(Ruben laughs)
- [Simu Liu] It's an amazing outfit.
- I'm in.
- So I'm gonna read a question, right?
And, and each person will answer
from strongly disagree to disagree,
somewhat disagree, somewhat agree,
agree and strongly agree.
And, and then we're gonna talk about it.
- That's right.
And the key is this is
a safe space for all.
So any, there's no right or wrong answer.
And also there's no neutral
but it's intended to
sometimes be meaningful.
Sometimes it's fun.
Sometimes it's spicy.
So you, if you feel the need
to go there, let's go there.
- [Ruben] Let's go.
- Okay (laughs).
Let's go.
- All right.
- You ready?
- All right, America.
You ready?
Let's go.
- Okay.
Let's get vulnerable.
Here's the question.
It's okay to stay in touch with an ex.
Lock in your choices.
I'm gonna, I got my iPad,
I'm gonna lock in mine.
Alright.
Does everybody, you guys, you guys got it?
- [Jason] Good.
- On the count of three.
- Okay.
- One, two, three.
- Whoa
- Disagree.
- Somewhat-
- Somewhat agree.
Okay, so, Ruben and I-
- Yeah.
- Ruben and I are kind of
on the same wavelength here.
Well, okay.
I'll, I'll start.
I mean, I think I lightly agree.
It's okay to stay.
I mean, stay in touch just means
to have some sort of points of contact.
I think-
- Right.
- I think first of all,
it's healthy to end off relationships
on amicable terms.
And so think it's fine to, you know,
stay in touch once in a while,
just say, "Hey, hope you're
hope you're doing well".
Maybe a happy birthday.
I don't necessarily
think it's great for you
to be best friends with an ex.
- Like super close.
- Right.
And that's why you disagree.
- I think so.
I think that in theory,
I'm totally there with you.
I think I've just learned in practice
that I'm not able to do it.
- Mm.
- And now I'm like, it's just
not playing with fire
per se but it's like,
"Oh, okay, I don't know
if I would be comfortable
if my, my now wife Mel is like
chatting up her ex boyfriend in the-
- Yeah, yeah.
It's kinda like, what are you do-
You know, if, if you have,
if you're trying to like
re you know, you have
some sort of a vestige
of your previous connection
why are you trying to foster-
- I think you run into each
other at the grocery store
you should be cordial, but I'm just not,
I just don't think I would
go outta my way to be like,
let's be chatting.
- Fair enough.
- All right.
I'm not afraid of the ex man.
See here's the thing.
(Jason and Simu Liu laughing)
You can't take my girl.
I can only lose her, okay?
So nobody can take my girl.
That being said, if the ex was respectable
to the relationship, great.
And after the breakup,
you never double dipped.
All right?
If you never went back
and reheated the macaroni,
you're good to go.
- It's never as good the second time.
- It's never as good.
- That's right.
- I'm just saying.
That's what I'm saying.
- I like it.
I like it.
- Wow.
What uh, wise words from
our amazing hype man, Ruben.
- Giving relationship advice.